Remember that friend of yours who got
rich dropshipping, day trading, buying
crypto, and wholesaling all at the same
time, right? Me neither. And so today,
you'll watch a single mom of five who
could potentially be making much, much
more, but she keeps launching new
businesses and she's incredibly spread
thin and overwhelmed. If you've ever
been in her situation where you have
constant FOMO and you keep chasing new
opportunities, this video might save you
years of your life. Let's just start
with playing the clip. So last year, my
company made a million. I've already
made a million this year, so I think I'm
on track for four, but I hope to hit 10.
So, here's the deal, okay? Is that I get
really bored, right? And so, I'm also a
really amazing visionary. And so, I've
built a lot of different things. And
what I'm needing right now is I need
clarity, okay? And I need you to I would
love for you to help me focus. Okay? I'm
going to share with you what I've done.
I'm going to share with you what I have.
And then what I would love for you to
show me is how do I get clarity? Okay.
What do you sell? Yeah. So I have a
publishing house. Okay. But really what
I've sold is that I take people on these
fiveday adventures, like luxury
adventures, and I can help people
channel their books in 5 days. And
that's what's filled my pocket. But it's
also just not scalable. And why is it
not scalable? Well, because one week a
month I'm on these adventures and I love
it, but it's like there's like a
ceiling. And so then I like rented this
island in the middle of the British
Virgin Islands. I took 15 people there.
We all write their books for five days.
And so that was like scalable, which
that landed me a TV show. So now I have
like this TV show, but then I have like
like my publishing house. And then like
I have this business school for women.
Yeah. And then like I'm also like a
single mom of five kids. Also, I like
write books on the corner. Also, I did a
live event in January and closed 1.25 25
million in five minutes to a crowd of
30. So it's like I have all these things
I just like I just need some
So she's got a lot going on as you can
imagine. But the thing is is like before
I had kind of like my big
entrepreneurial breakthrough. I had my
six gyms. I had a chiropractor uh
agency. I had a dental agency. And then
I had the turnaround launch business
where I was flying out and doing done
for you sales. So I had nine different
businesses and I was doing around the
same revenue that Kira says here. I was
doing, you know, a few million dollars a
year. I was so spread thin and so
overwhelmed. And the thing is is like if
you want to unlock like super super
success in my opinion, you have to
concentrate your energy like you have a
magnifying glass from the sun. Think
about your potential or your
intelligence or your work ethic as like
the size of the magnifying glass, which
is the more you know sun it captures. So
you have potential, but it doesn't
matter how big the magnifying glass is
that's capturing the sun. If it's not
focused on one point, it's not gonna do
anything. Yeah. You gotta pick. You got
to pick one of your five kids.
The 10-year-old all day. There you go.
So, you just got to you got to think
about which one's the 10-year-old of
your businesses.
The thing is is the more talented you
are, the more opportunities you know you
could crush, which just means more
things you have to say no to. And it's
just like it's the reality of it. I mean
the thing is is there's a price to that
which is um if you continue to doing
what you're currently doing
you pay a price on either side on if you
continue you pay the price of how big
the impact you want to have and how big
of a business you ultimately build.
That's the price. What you get for that
trade is you get to have the novelty and
the excitement of new things happening
all the time. On the other side, you
build something really big um that has
teams and systems and it just, you know,
grows really large, probably maybe maybe
not bigger than your vision, but large,
much larger than what you have right
now. Uh and what you give up for that um
is all of the novelty that's associated
with doing your things.
Yeah.
So, which one? Well, it sounds like you
know which one you should do and you
want to do something different. I feel
like when I when I've been looking at
like, okay, well, what has brought
people to me? It's always the books and
I keep trying to get out of it because
there's so many people and there's so
many things and all these systems in
publishing and I'm like, but if I just
ran the business school, like I don't
have to have all these like editors and
formatterers and book covers and Right.
But then I look at like, well, what do
people always come to me for? It's
always books. Mhm.
Yeah. This is, you know, Alex's two
cents. Well, you're on my channel, so I
guess I guess it's okay for me to share
my two cents. There's big visionary
stuff, and then there's just kind of
like real everyday business. And so I'm
going to give the real everyday business
perspective on this. Go where the
money's at. If everybody comes and says,
"Hey, I want to give you money to do
something." Or, "Hey, I want to buy this
thing from you over and over again."
Listen, that's feedback from the
marketplace to use the, you know, fancy
business jargon. If everybody comes to
you and says, "Hey, please solve this
big problem for me. You're really good
at it and I don't know any else who can
do it." It's like, "That's amazing.
Means you can build a business around
that." In my business career, every
business I've had has not been like the
thing that I thought it was going to be
when I started. Almost every time I have
this idea of like, "Oh, wouldn't it be
cool if," right? And then what happens
is I end up going to the marketplace and
people are like, "I actually want this."
And I'm like, really? Huh? Wild. Okay.
And so I have to sometimes it's massive
pivots that end up happening. But it's
like you need to be a blood hound for
for for value. And the way that you are
a blood hound for value is you solve
other people's problems which they give
you which you know you've solved them
because they give you money to do it. If
I have three different doors that people
can come in and they keep knocking on
one and I'm like don't why don't you why
don't you buy two or three? Two or three
are great. It's like well they're like I
just want one. instead of just being
like trying to get them into two and
three, just crush one and then remove
all the other doors and then go all in
on that. So, you run the business
school, right? Yeah. So, imagine I come
to you Mhm. and I'm saying, "Hey, I've
got this business that everybody wants
to buy from me. It has good margins. I
sell it like crazy, but I have like four
other businesses that I want to start.
They don't grow as quickly as this other
one. What should I do?"
Weird. Sounds so easy when you say it.
Yeah, obviously. Right. Right. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
What you're encountering is a is a
problem I think everybody in this room
has dealt with, right? It sucks. It's
like you have to realize that like you
can't pursue every opportunity. Not only
can you not approach every opportunity,
you basically have to say no to every
opportunity to be able to make one
opportunity worth pursuing. If my TV
show is on Amazon Prime and I'm helping
people write books and then I'm like,
but I'm pushing my business school.
Like, that doesn't even make sense.
Yeah. I wouldn't push the business
school. Just have the media asset of
Prime that pushes you writing books and
then help people write more books and
then have a second season of Amazon
Prime helping you, you know, people
writing books and then sell more people
writing books. Yeah. All right. Like,
that's my financial adviser on the front
shaking her head. We got this, Julia.
Yeah, Julia was like, "I've seen the
financials on the book one. Like, do
more of that." Right. I had these these
massive multi-year plateaus where I just
stayed stuck because I wanted to pursue
every single thing. Yeah. And so, you
have to trade novelty for loyalty. And
so, it's like you become loyal to the
business. I also think that occurs with
relationships like you make the trade
the new person everyone, you know, every
week, every month, every whatever for
somebody that you know that you've built
something meaningful that's deeper,
right? And I think that you it's kind of
like I think business in a lot of ways
is like a fine wine where like you
understand it at a different level um as
the years go by and you go through
different seasons. And I think that you
miss out on that opportunity if you're
going after you know one night stands
and flings
from a business perspective. Do you know
my life?
Yeah, you have to like life will not
give you what you want if you want
everything.
Damn. like we we have to make trades or
we get nothing
and it's tough. And I think there was a
big I had a big realization I want to
say a few years back where um once I
realized how much work it takes to make
something truly great and something big.
I had this moment of like deep sadness
where I realized that I could only do a
few things throughout the rest of my
life. I was like, "Oh, I only have like
two maybe three entrepreneurial seasons
left in me." Yeah. Which is kind of like
crazy to think about. It's like I only
get two or three more big swings. That's
it. And the real real is that if the
swing just keeps going, which is what I
plan on doing, acquisition.com, it's
like this is it. I'm going to do this
until I get too old to do it. And that's
it. That's all it is. Now, what I want
to do is give you something tactical.
All right? Because that's this is we
were all the way up here. You have to
take your creative energy, and I have a
lot of that, too. Um, and you have to
channel it into something that is
accreative to the business, something
that adds value rather than something
that detracts value. And so, what are
the components of the business that need
novelty on a regular basis?
Um, I think I can give you a hint. What?
Marketing. Marketing. I was just going
to say sales and marketing magnets.
Yeah. Like, so if you want to build and
you want to create, I have the same
itch. Yeah. I put all of my ADD into
content. I've become a significantly
better entrepreneur by making content
because it distracts me from [__] up
my business.
This is legit. I just wrote a book about
this.
I just wrote a book about when leaders
get bored, they just [__] it all up and
burn down the city. Yeah. And I just
keep doing it over and over. So instead
just like just paint the city. Okay.
Just paint it. Don't destroy it. Just
paint a different color. Got it. And so
that like and that goes for everyone
like my my ADD like I put it into ads. I
put it into like the reason I write
books is mostly for me. Like Ila's like
can you just write another book? Because
she's like you're just getting into all
of these things that you should just not
get into. Right. Yeah. And so the thing
is is that when I am in writing mode,
the business does exceptionally well
because I do so little. Yeah. Right.
Feel this. Yeah. I don't normally um
talk about this, but I think this will
this this feels incredibly relevant.
So
this is going to feel real for you.
Yeah. Uh and everyone else. So let's
imagine the business like everyone's
revenue here represents this like this
this line your revenue not aggregate but
like this is that's your business.
That's normal business that's happening.
What I realized, this is me, so this is
anecdotal, is that whenever I decide to
make a change in the business, I see
about a 20% decrement or decrease in
performance um from whatever that change
is. So I change a sales process, I
change a leader process, I change an
onboarding process, I change something
that I have to train people up on
something new. Now, even if that change
is something that I think is superior,
I'm still going to have an immediate
decrease in performance. Now, what what
if if I if I assume this to be true,
which in my experience, it's been about
20%. So if you're like what's the data
research behind it? It's Alex doing
this. All right. Now if I think that
this improvement is going to make let's
say a 5% improvement in the business
like I think this will you know improve
our our closing rate by 5% or something
like that then I'm going to take a
guaranteed 20% loss for a potential 5%
increase.
Bad trade. Now how many months is it
going to take me in order to make up for
the 20, you know, 20%. It's going to
take four or five months, right? And
it's gonna Now, here's the really fun
thing is that on an alternate timeline,
you have this thing, but when you leave
people alone,
they tend to just get better at their
jobs. So, you'll get the 5% improvement.
And so, what's happened is that I've
actually created this rule,
which is that if I don't see a an
adjusted a riskadjusted 20% improvement.
So, let me explain what I mean by that,
which is I need to see a 40% improvement
that I think has a 50/50 shot at
happening
for me to make any change at all. Damn.
Let's say that you are going to run a
test of some sort. You want to change
your sales process, change something on
a landing page, you want to I mean
change anything, right? You have some
belief that it's going to improve,
right? You wouldn't do it unless you
thought there was a chance that it would
improve the business, right? Of course
not. But the thing is is that what is
that chance? And so your ability to
estimate I think we have a 50-50 shot. I
think we have an 8020 shot. I think we
have a 2080 shot that this actually
works then allows you to over time get
better and better at estimating what the
potential upside is for a given
intervention. And so if I know something
is going to go down by 20% no matter
what because I change something and that
20% decrease comes from training team
and people kind of dealing with change.
That's the price tag of trying. So the
thing is like you don't have unlimited
shots. So people talk about testing all
the time. Test test test. Yeah. But
there's also a cost to test. And so if
you think you can maybe run only one
test like even on even on something
that's automated like landing pages. If
you change multiple things at once, you
don't know where the the the correct
attribution is like what actually made
the benefit or the the decrease, right?
And so you really only have like 52
tests a year. You've got about one a
week that you can maybe do with
sufficient volume of traffic. Right?
Right now maybe you have two or three
different areas you know funnels that
you could do it on but even then there's
actually significantly fewer tests that
you can run. Now in the people side of
the business it is way less than one a
week. You're talking okay maybe you
think one a month. I don't know. It's
like we just did this this month. Are we
going to really change the process
again? So maybe you've got like one a
quarter. So you've got like four shots
maybe that you're going to change in a
department in terms of a true change
that's going to occur in terms of
process. And the thing is is most
entrepreneurs number one don't think
about it like they've got a punch card
that only has four changes on it. And so
I kind of like this from the Warren
Buffett's perspective of like picking
stocks and investing. He said if
everybody just had a punch card where
they could only make 20 investments
their whole life, people would do it
exceptionally well because it forces you
to actually think, am I really buying
this company? Am I really doing it for
the long term? Do I really believe in
this? And so to the same degree you as
an entrepreneur, we've got like one
punch a quarter. And the bigger the
company is, sometimes it's even fewer
than that. And so if you only had you're
like, "All right, is this the is this
the bet I'm going to make?" Like this is
the shot on goal that I want to take of
all the different bets, all the
different ideas that I have. This is the
one that I think has the highest upside
and highest likelihood of happening. And
so by me shifting my perspective on this
and when I when I have so I have this
big massive list of ideas, which we'll
talk about in a second in the video, um
I put an estimated value next to it. I
think how much do I believe this could
improve and how likely is it? And so
when I have that, I can rank order these
and then when we do have bandwidth, I'm
like, "Okay, I think it's time to try
this one." But it's better be worth it
because the price tag no matter what is
that your business gets worse. And so I
have a list right now. Mhm. Um it's
Alex's big list of ideas. Yeah. Which I
encourage you to have. Okay. And I have
it. It's on my phone. Um where every
time I think of something else that we
could do to improve this business,
instead of messaging the team and
saying, "Hey guys, emergency meeting.
We're going to do this. this is such a
great idea.
I just write it down. Yeah. And I just
keep living my life. Okay.
And every once in a while I'll have one
where I'm like, this is actually a 40
50%, you know, potential move. Then I'll
go to the team and say, here's my
reasoning behind this. And then they'll
say, cool, you have four other 50%
return moves that you've told us about
in the last 30 days. is this better than
those ones? And then I'll look at it, be
like, no, it's not better than those
ones. And so then I'll keep it on my
list. And in the event that the entire
team has bandwidth and they're all
breathing a little too easy, then I can
go destroy their worlds, right?
But what's ended up happening is that my
businesses have improved so dramatically
by me just saying, let's just let's just
let people do their jobs. And so I'm
gonna be crude yet again just to
emphasize this point, which is that I
have grown to accept that some [__]
stays [__] Yeah. And so there are
tons of things about the experience that
you guys went through today. Hopefully
it's been really positive between
yesterday and today. I hope it has been.
The team was great. But there's probably
a hundred things that I want to improve
about it. But every time I want to go
improve one of those things, four others
drop. And it's not worth the cost of
change.
And so most of us just don't factor in
the guaranteed 20% decrease for the
potential which we are usually overly
optimistic on. I think this will be 40%.
But then after it is all said and done
it's five. Was that worth it? No. And so
hopefully this is not you know this is
I'm not just talking to you. I can see a
lot of heads nodding. Um this has been
one of the most useful razors that I've
used as an entrepreneur and it has made
all of my business significantly better.
I realized that there was this decrease
in performance every time I change
something because I have had enough fast
speed fast feedback loops across
different departments. And so like if we
have something in sales and I want to
change the the sales process, I know
that the first week we change something
in the scripting, even if we think it's
better, the team's going to take a
second to adjust, right? Like they have
muscle memory. They got to rebuild that
muscle memory. um when we would you know
even change an onboarding process like I
know that people are going to drop the
ball they're going to mess something up
in the beginning but then like they got
to get their reps in and they can fix it
um in the advisory practice which has
been you know um super successful at
acquisition.com helping you know helping
businesses scale uh that aren't
necessarily like you know ready for
investment um we've been able to like
you know tweak many things about the
process but I do know that every time we
do make a change I can see the decrease
in performance before I see the
increase. Now, we do get to the
increase, but every time I I have to
bear that cost, I'm like, h, I don't
know if I want to change something
again. And I think a lot of reasons that
entrepreneurs don't realize it is
because they don't track. And so, we are
I will say like one of the things that
we're pretty good at is like we're very
good at tracking data at
acquisition.com. And so, we have a very
I I have very good metrics that get
pumped to me. And so, I can I can I can
see the pain. And if you're too far away
from it, you don't see the change in
customer satisfaction, the change in NPS
scores, the change in, you know,
ascension rates, the change in churn,
the change in whatever it is. If you
don't have real-time metric, if you're
looking at something on a monthly basis
and you make a change and then the next
week like again nothing happens, the
next week nothing happens. Then you get,
you know, numbers in reverse, you know,
one month or three months later and
they're not even necessarily accurate or
they're very vague or they're fudged and
they're or there's multiple data streams
that are conflicting, right? All those
things make it very difficult for you to
see clearly the cost of the things that
you're doing. But the real real
underneath of this is that the vast
majority of entrepreneurs are changing
so many things so often that they never
know what was the thing that broke
besides them.
And so tactical takeaway for you is
number one, channel your ADD into the
stuff that benefits the business by
being creative. Number two, make a list
of all your crazy ideas when they come
up and don't tell anyone about them.
Okay? And if it seasons for two or four
weeks and you still think about it, it's
like maybe when you go to the store,
you're like, "Maybe I'll buy this
dress." I don't know. I'm just
pretending to be a girl for a second.
And then you decide not to. And it's
like if you still think about the dress
a month later, then go back and buy it.
But in the moment, if you buy it, then
it's usually a terrible decision. And so
it's the same thing with this. Put the
list down, sleep on it. If you're still
thinking about that idea a month later,
it probably has some legs. Yeah. Right.
And then number three, if I am going to
pull something off of my big list of
crazy ideas, it better be worth it
because I'm going to absolutely detonate
a bomb in my business and it better be
worth what's going to happen when the
dust settles. Wow.
This was hard for me to hear
and like everything I needed. Thank you.
Cool.
[Applause]
Thank you guys. Hey guys. So, if you're
seeing uh Kira, who's the lovely lady in
this um video, and you see kind of the
people around, that's at our actual
headquarters here in Vegas. And so, if
you're a business owner and you're, you
know, feeling stuck or you're not sure
what the next step is uh to maybe have
to pivot the business or you're just
scaling well and you're like, I just
want to make sure that I can pay down my
ignorance tax and just keep the scaling
going. Uh we'd love to help. We'd love
to meet you in person. And the reason
that I even decided to do this in person
thing at my office is that like it's not
scalable. Um, and it's almost like
purposely not scalable. And so it's just
very cool for us. I think it's like it's
deep, right? Like we get to actually
meet you like I'll meet you. Um, and
really get to know the business, right?
And get to know you and um, and provide
the the the highest value I possibly
can. Um, and so the reason I was willing
to do that is because I think word of
mouth travels faster than the amount of
people that I can fit into a room. Um,
and so we try to make it, you know,
absolutely exceptional experience and,
um, the reviews seem to indicate that
people really, really like it a lot. Um,
and so yeah, so if you are a business
owner and you have been like on the
fence or debating, um, you know, a big
decision that's coming up or like what
the missing link is or you know, where
you need to focus in the business where
you can get the most returns, um, that's
our bread and butter. That's what we do
every day. Um, and yeah, we'd love to
have you out. So, I'm sure there's a
link somewhere. You can probably click
it and get stuff
and book go with us.